oh that's real nice you don't want it no
I really do
I need to make a call hello how can I
help knows everybody's gonna get fixed
up there for you memberships and we're
off to the races the autumns
it is a secret hospital for criminals
but you are done with all this I got out
but you know it goes never out not a few
I thought this place was a myth
we've been here for 22 years this
hospital was built on two things
trust the rules you see that badge
that means I'm a healthcare professional
you're nice either right don't push my
buttons don't you do that
I'm a professional but this woman she's
the business if you knew what she could
do to you with just that cup of coffee
you're lucky this place is rose the
audience isn't safe for us because it is
it's a portable vault or it's about 18
million wolf kings probably gonna want
those back okay this is a real problem
it's here okay that's against the rules
rules that Doolittle breakers honey
where would you be
you got like a plan you're my brother I
love you
3d printing complete I got the next best
thing I got it go yes my ballroom j0
okay
there's a war zone up here I gotta make
it out of here
we can do it together this is what I did
visiting hours are never busy night at
the Artemis
you know you might want to buy some
scented candles or something cuz it
smells like somebody died did
you